the jurogan experience what did you say
that bert made a video
of the homeless it was on his instagram
i'll see if i can pull it up because uh
crusher he was driving up highland
avenue in hollywood
and was just saying like he wasn't
showing the whole video during it but he
was like at a stop lightning like there
was
tents the whole way up here and he's
like strange like this is also a really
nice tent
people want me to talk to bird crashers
hi
bert look at bert the machine
oh this it's in his instagram story that
[ __ ] his stories will go on for
years for a long time he goes does him
every 15 seconds might even be deleted
now
it's crazy i think productivity wise is
basically the elon musk of instagram
stories
because it's not showing up or it could
be one of these
is it well there's so there it is
there's tents all the way up on highland
people living on the side of the street
this is [ __ ] insane
this is literally hundreds of tents
everywhere
uh by the way that's a nice [ __ ] tent
also those are two very nice tents i
wonder if the city's giving them out
because we don't have a tent that nice i
mean i'm not even joking our tent
isn't even that nice wow
that's uh that's a tiny uh image he
showed you know you didn't get to see
the real
homeless situation but bridget fettucy
sent me a video when she was driving by
venice
and it's a minute and a half long of
just straight tents
as she's driving down the road just
nothing but tense
yeah how do you put that genie back in
the bottle lex well that this is
oh you mean it's a slippery slope now
listen i've been thinking about
you know a bunch of tech folks who are
moving to austin right
in terms of uh in terms of starting
businesses so
that's one of the questions they're
asking like where is this headed and
you're talking about the homeless
problem
well the governor just today came out
and said
that if uh the city does not reimpose
a ban on camping that the state is going
to step in
well yeah because people are there
there's safety concerns people are
openly defecating on the streets
there's uh you know it's not nearly as
bad here as it is in california but it's
way worse here than i've ever seen it
before
but you know homelessness is it feels
like that's a symptom
not the problem right i mean is that
uh it's hard to say because homelessness
was horrific
in san francisco before the pandemic
right and the concern is that
when you are too lenient
on the homeless folks and just allow
them to camp whenever they wherever they
want [ __ ] wherever they want
they just do it and if you don't put up
rules
if you try to be progressive and
open-minded it's like these are they'd
like to have new words for them like the
unhoused and [ __ ] like that
and when you do that you open up the
door for more of them to migrate there
because there's like there was a video
that somebody put up of them
interviewing these homeless guys
like why do you like san francisco and
they said first of all they give us food
they give us money
they they let us you know they're really
loose they let us camp wherever we want
and these guys had
moved to san francisco to be homeless
which is a problem but see just like you
said that problem is tied up with the
fact that a lot of people are
struggling financially because so yeah
it feels like trying to solve the
homelessness problem
is in direct tension with trying to
take care of people who are struggling
well i think
it shows that there's a problem with
people
losing a place to live and that the
solution is not necessarily let them
camp out anywhere they want i think
there should be some sort of a step
that the government takes whether it's
to develop housing
or to build something for them but when
you
let them just camp and [ __ ] everywhere
then you ruin all the other spaces
right like the best way to keep the city
intact
and to try to help these people is to
implement some sort of a program
where you provide housing for them
letting them just camp on the street
that's chaos like now you've you've
[ __ ] up
everything so this particular state
government just seems incompetent
at solving this particular problem but
it also seems to be not very good at
solving some other problems
right in terms of encouraging businesses
to
stay there california california yeah
yeah
well it's it's it's bad it's over
regulated it's a crazy regulated state
you know and it's also very high taxes
and
there's a lot of people that are
recognizing that there's other places
that don't have any state taxes like why
would i stay in a place that's
described it's they're they're telling
you you can't work they're closing down
businesses
gavin newsom today is there's a lawsuit
got filed by more than 50
san francisco bay area restaurants and
bars
trying to say like why why are we closed
like this doesn't make any sense
you should you can't just keep doing
this forever
and some places are starting to wake up
my hope
is that a lot of this is political as
gross as that sounds
and that now that biden and harris are
in that they'll open things back up and
the mayor of chicago said this the mayor
of new york has said we have to open
things back up
and i'm hoping interesting i'm hoping
that they take this chance
it could go the other way as well though
right it's
uh the other way is now that there is
a democrat in office that
they could see that as a path to to pass
further regulations
and push this close the economy go into
uh lock down further
why would they do that though i'd listen
i was
thought it was a terrible idea the the
long-term consequences on the economy
are going to be potentially orders of
magnitude worse
on our like the fabric of our society so
i don't know why they would do that the
so the michael mouse so the devil on my
shoulder okay michael's devil
wearing a white suit uh or the devil
wears a suit and tie right
yeah that's a badass i've been listening
to that
how good is that guy that guy's amazing
and your story
uh sorry in a small tangent your story
that he doesn't he hasn't been on your
podcast because
he's working on a ranch like as a
[ __ ] rancher
that's legit like we reached out to them
he's like well he's working on the ranch
right now
like what is he doing on that ranch he's
a [ __ ] cowboy like a legit cowboy
like there's literally no more badass
thing to do than turn down
uh joe rogan experience uh appearance
massive promotion he's like yeah i'd
rather just rope steers
yeah but the michael malus devil uh
argument is that
you know that's one way for the
government to gain more control or the
populace
is uh to fear monger say that there's a
big problem
yeah and that magnify the the sort of
the narrative around how big that
problem is
and unfortunately from my perspective as
a
scientist to use scientists to say look
scientists are saying there's a huge
problem
sort of use science as a tool of fear
mongering
and then gain further and further
control of the populace that's the devil
on the on the shoulder you have to have
an incentive to do that like why would
they want that kind of control while
also devastating the economy they need
the economy because they need tax
revenue if they're not
getting tax revenue how are they going
to feed the military-industrial complex
how are they going to feed all their
businesses how are they going to feed
the pharmaceutical industry
like what all these people that finance
their campaigns
and all these banks that pay for them to
speak after they get out of office
where's the money coming from now if
there's no economy i don't think that
i think that's like one of them doom and
gloom q anon type deals
where people are thinking like this is
they want to kill half the population
and
you know yeah no i agree with you
everything you said
incentive wise it makes sense catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience for
free
only on spotify watch back catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience